[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a good one right there
I've never stopped him before right well
we made good time today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't you go in the slingshot bomb
anything from piggy island nope
Chuck anything to the north nope
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
those pigs are gonna pay for our lunches
because of our hunger to give them a
taste of their own quesadillas all right
I'm sorry guys we're taking over the
blue line official business
anything for you red hey isn't it funny
how nobody likes you until you save bird
island but now we all love you ha thanks
so much for bringing that up
ok ready 3 2 2 bombs you say 1 all right
why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you mess with the hatchlings you get my
cannonball ready big day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
not on my watch
sorry guys excuse me sir but I believe
this belongs to you don't don't stop you
should probably that's not coming from
Rhode Island what the heck is that and
where did it come from
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot
[Music]
another successful day of protecting the
island great job guys what can I say
that's what I do now watch just go ahead
and run along and keep your big cute
eyes peeled for the next pig prank all
right
okay let's just finish clean up the rest
of these crabs and then we can move on
to what is that oh look it seems like
it's some kind of note Oh what if it's a
love note what if it's like a message in
a bottle or a genie in a bomb guys
there's no bottle so just you know stop
dear Birds we humbly request a truce can
we talk love letters xoxo oh nice try
piggies news flash we're not idiots
hey ear burs you are idiots but we are
serious about the troops
Oh
[Music]
let me see that one of their pranks huh
oh relief right I mean who else was
getting really tired of all that comes
in breaking every tally Asian big this
guy hired no no guys look I'll imagine
all the fun things we can do now I can
think of you think I'll go and I think
resume no no guys we are working
tirelessly day and night to save the
world but the world doesn't need saving
right of course they need us huh come
here honey what are you so afraid of
afraid of what do I have to be afraid of
[Music]
I'm not afraid of anything okay you know
what I'm just gonna write you a
prescription for one night of fun with
your cool friends especially Chuck with
us what are you talking come with you -
what buddy we can't tell you because we
definitely wouldn't be into it
[Music]
[Music]
now we have all your eggs yeah nothing
you could do about it
red like going going piggies cuz you're
gonna be crying in a second right take
your back then take those rats eggs huh
you said walks instead of eggs again
oh sorry they all walks
don't cry Sam Sam I'll be right back
[Music]
my sisters for a minute now we will we
have all your eggs yeah
and there's nothing you could do about
it red oink oink oink oink oink you're
gonna be crying your second right take
your bets and take dollar I know we've
had our differences come in peace
I don't want to see your face any more
than you want to see mine
we're all in danger from you know we
have a truth this is not how a truth
were just say what you gotta say read
we've discovered that there's a third
island and they're plotting to destroy
us all Berdych island give me one good
reason why I should believe you
I'll show you the proof will Team six
[Music]